[Musique]
l'archipel japonais
dans 20 ans le nombre de chiens atteint
des proportions colossales
une épidémie de grippe canine se répand
à travers la ville de médéa qui le maire
monsieur kobayashi ordonne des mesures
d'urgence et réclament une quarantaine
rapide de l'île poubelles devient un
lieu d'exil l'île aux chiens
je crois que j'en peux plus d'un valet
ses ordures les mots de la bouche
personne ne renonce aussi à leur tâche
est de ne jamais l'oublier
jamais tu t'appelles rex toits qu'il
doit duke toit basse et moi chef on est
une meute effrayante de mâles alphas
destructibles xj 750
et il a posé sur l'île pour un chien
[Musique]
pensant j'étais trouve craquant on a
saisi l'idée du recherche ton chien
perdu spot coca cola
[Musique]
ce poste s'il est en vie pourrait tout
aussi bien être ce moment même retenu
prisonnier captifs paca mais j'aurai
quelque chose se voulait très petits
pilotes
pourquoi le jeune parce que c'est un
petit garçon de 12 ans les chaînes cet
or on va le retrouver uni soit c'est
encore hui on va retrouver ton chien
dommage que personne à part le salon
au nord un long pont jetée branlant au
dessus d'un marais debout nocives menant
à une décharge radioactifs polluée par
des déchets chimiques toxiques
c'est notre destination super
préparez-vous à sauter